thank you thank you so hello everyone
this is going to be interesting
apparently many people like a dirty B
front end and C tricks so that's pretty
cool now it's not going to be easy
because you know I don't want to do the
hard work so you you're going to do the
hard work the way we're going to do it
because they are really dirty I have to
warn you first the things are going to
see you will not be able to unsee and I
don't take any credit or responsibility
of what happens next once you saw them
right they are really bad like seriously
bad so we'll see how it goes now the way
it's going to go just to be a bit more
fun
I brought some chocolate with me so I'm
going to post challenges and we're going
to probably cover like 10 or 15
challenges and if you think that you
have a good idea just shout and I'll try
my best to throw the little piece of
chocolate at you I don't take any credit
or responsibility of whether I hit you
or not right again but this is going to
be fun alright so let's go now this is
me this is how you stole flag back in
the day things do change over time I
currently do live in Vilnius in the
Vienna which is why this check out is
from Vilnius Lithuania but I'm still
editing most of the stuff and smashing
and also I do a lot of consultancy these
days they spend a lot of time in
companies and companies real fun
sometimes especially the enterprise-e
corporate and you know this kind of
thing because they tend up to find to
kind of come up with really interesting
pragmatic solutions to anything right
people can solve everything seriously in
a interesting creative way so let's see
all right you ready that doesn't sound
very exciting you have to talk to me
already all right this is better all
right so let's have some simple stuff
that's not too complicated I think so
here's the task for you right so what if
you need to nest one link inside another
for example inside notes footnotes or
articles when you want the entire
excerpt to be linked but you also want
the excerpt to contain potentially
contain links which lead to another site
right so you might encounter things like
that
right I have a product image maybe or
product description so you have a block
of text right which is a link but at the
same time you might have links inside of
that paragraph which should stay links
as well now how would you do it without
JavaScript can you have nested links in
HTML that's not very clear to me at this
point so if you say yes you have to tell
the eye how you do it
anybody button and an anchor inside not
sure about that okay somebody said
object
who said object all right so here we go
I'm trying my best here come on
seriously so there are many solutions
right so one thing that we could do
potentially is of course use
position:absolute to put the link on top
of the paragraph and also use that index
to kind of make it work
but you know we can use object type
because it's fancier why well if we
actually try to nest a link inside of
another link what browser is going to do
is assume that you're stupid and it's
going to close the first thing for you
but it's not going to reopen it so in
the end you end up with this part of the
paragraph not being a link anymore right
which is the problem now we can solve it
why well how well by just putting up the
anchor inside of the object tag why the
hell would you do that because object
behaves very much like SVG or iframe if
you think if you like so the browser
will actually just ignore whatever is
inside so it won't say it's so dirty
everything that's inside objects so
dirty I'm not even going to touch it so
I'm going to keep it as it is so it's
going to work just as expected right now
I don't say that this is cool and this
is you there's something that you should
do but it's useful to know this because
if you encounter situation when you
can't use JavaScript for some reason
kind of close link opening closing
opening then you can actually use it and
in fact if you want to make it work
in older ie you can use conditional
comments inside object which is probably
the worst thing I ever said in my life
but you know this does work and if you
feel really comfortable with this or
uncomfortable you can look at the
kittens if you do feel comfortable you
can read the entire article which
the entire thing or again you can just
use position:absolute on top of the
paragraph but object is really awesome
for two reasons actually first of all
because everybody hates it and second of
all because you can actually embed SVG's
in a very smart way now there are many
ways of embedding SVG on the page right
um you can do it in line you can you
know you can just use image source and
background image and so on but have you
tried to embed an SVG file on the page
using the object tag this is awesome
right
why well first of all if you actually
embed it in the regular way just by
using image source or background I'm
kind of cold and sorry dense kind of
blocks as access to the SVG path so if
we have an SVG on SVG file it contains
some paths that we want to you know
change the thickness of or change the
color we can't do it if we embed it this
way right we can inline it but then it's
not cacheable which is a problem we can
also base64 it but it's again the same
story so what can we do well this is the
best thing we can do sitting by actually
so we can embed it as inside of the
object tag using just a proper type
attribute and then inside of the object
SVG thing inside of the SVG file we can
use media queries and JavaScript and CSS
and whatever you like and this CSS can
be styling can actually style the actual
path on whatever we have in the SVG just
you know on hover or whatever whatever
you want to do now this works really
well in even in those old browsers right
that's pretty cool
it's good to know that we can use that
all right here's another one now by
default we know I mean we're going to
have lots of them so get ready
by default broken images look freaking
spectacular right so if there is
actually any way to improve the
experience by changing the styling if
images are actually broken right because
this is what we're getting most of the
time if an image cannot be loaded then
we're going to get this little
placeholder finger with a broken image
inside it does not very you know cool
can you change it how
mm okay tough drop I see who said that
okay I'm pretty good today I'm seriously
right so here's the interesting part
that you need to know now the image
element if you look in the spec you'll
find lots of really interesting stuff in
there the image element is a so-called
replaced element it's an element whose
appearance and dimensions are defined by
an external resource make sense however
absolute elements should not work on it
unless the image cannot be lauded so
even the image can not be lauded the
before and after two tournaments will be
applied and they will not be applied if
an image is loaded right so we can do
all kind of starting to improve the
experience of the you know broken images
without doing too much at this point and
it just works we just apply before and
after to image and voila you're done I
see a lot of excitement in here it's
great it's going great right so this
works really well okay but maybe this is
not too practical so let's talk about
something really practical something
that you probably should be using every
single day on every single project so we
like fluid type right and we often have
to implement fluid typography to make
sure that everything scales up and down
beautifully as designers intend to do it
right now how do we do it well if you
wanted to be really fluid you will
probably tighten up the font size
together with the VH OVW unit right so
all the time whenever the browser is
Croesus the window whenever the browser
window increases you also will have the
increase in the font size it's great but
then you know it can even grow
infinitely and it can become very very
small which is kind of not what we want
we want to have nice boundaries right
this is what would love to achieve and
we wanted to be reduced kind of scale up
and down nicely but not necessarily
proportionally just growing like nuts or
getting smaller we wanted to be kind of
in control now the problem is following
now we could use something like this
right okay just set the font size being
the calc of 1 M plus 1 plus 1 BW right
we we double use of course 1% of the
viewport width right now that works but
then in that case 1 am why do we
it well because we want to have kind of
minimum font size right that's okay
that helps us but not quite now now we
can do something like this when we just
included like for VW and for the agent
to be mean for example and we'll all
scale up and down but what if we're
talking about the pro graphics scale we
don't just want something to grow we
want to have a specific kind of not
breakpoints but specific docking points
where the type will grow to wards so
converge towards right so what if we
wanted to choose a font size of 16
pixels at the screen resolution of 400
pixels and then we wanted to transition
to 24 pixels at a resolution of 800 can
we do it without the break point a lot
of excitement in the room oh great all
right no but seriously can indeed have
any like a problem like this before or
design a country wants to have a nice
typographic scale like 1/3 or minus 3rd
or whatever and you have to build it how
would you build it so it scales down and
are beautifully everywhere no don't have
but no actually it's a bit more
complicated I just need to use a little
formula to make it work so that a second
that's okay that's okay it's going to
fun in reality it's not that complicated
so of course what do you have again we
have a special boundary I say between
400 pixels and 800 pixels and you have a
specific size like growth between
starting font size and final font size
right so you just plug it in here you've
got kind of the maximum subscreen size
minus minimum screen size where you're
talking about like the spectrum that
you're walking at and then here at this
point you're kind of subtracting 100%
100 PW minus 4 horn pixels at this point
you are getting to the area like what is
where am I either lower lower boundary
or in the upper boundary right and then
you multiply it with difference between
the maximum font size and mean font size
and you add the minimum font size and
you're done
that's really not complicated right so
the only thing you have to do is you
have to define all these four values
you've set them and you're done right
and then this is what it looks like so
you have your modular scale right
and all these headings including
typography like the body copy as well
are just going to flew it and kind of
grow naturally without you having to do
anything without even single media query
and without flexbox without anything
just with one little property that's
really cool right we actually published
an article about this which you can also
read on so in just in case you're
wondering calc is really damn good well
supported except you know who but we're
used to it right but this is not quite
what you want sometimes I mean that's
cool if you can just grow and and if the
font size can grow and actually become
smaller but what about the line height
because as we know from the Fogg Rafi
the smaller the font sizes or the small
the line lengths is the small the line
height should be as well and the other
way around
the largest their length is the taller
the line height should be as well can we
fix that maybe you want to have
something like this right automatically
without JavaScript without too many you
know fancy mate we're breaking points
just we want it to be fluid and just
right again we have the same problem
exactly right we have these two
boundaries let's say we have a minimum
line height one point free at some point
if it's smaller than that it's just not
going to work well right and also if
you're going to worry above 1.5 it's
going to be too wide right so we have
this nice boundary between 1.3 and 1 to
5 and we just need to define where it's
going to operate so it's going to
operate maybe in a layout between 21 mm
sent to 35 amps you plug it in the
formula you do a little bit of math
right you plug it's the formula and
you're done it's exactly the same story
just for the line height we're here
we've got we got the full range of
paragraph width in here 35 minus 21 then
some point in here we we just look at
the account we need to open numerator to
see how close we are to the upper
boundary and then we also need to
multiply it with the difference in terms
of wine height to get to this proper
factor
and then we also add the minimum phone
line height at this point and we're done
right and that's really really amazing
and in the end you get this which
without media queries again without
flexbox without anything it just works
right and if you actually make the
window a little bit smaller please
whatever yes that's okay we saw it
already
just move on I'll get the life yes/no or
whatever but it will actually work as
expected all right here's the next one
so how do you make sure that a
multi-column table both a row and a
column are highlighted on hava and on
tap now highlighting the current draw is
easy we can just use TR hover but what
about the column this is what we want
right we want to be able to kind of tap
on 22 and we want both the column and
the role to be highlighted without
JavaScript who was that okay not my best
one yeah we can just use two the ones
because this is the best thing you can
have in CSS so this has a few magical
properties which just work everywhere
and like like amazing area all the time
apes or elements and be flexbox if you
can't do something with in CSS try
flexbox if it doesn't work try more
flags box if it still has a more type
Sedonas this is my strategy for
everything I'm sorry I succeeded so far
so please try the two now how can we do
it with two elements without JavaScript
all right this is really nasty maybe you
should not be using CSS for this but you
can write so we can create huge pseudo
and on top of that table that we have
with a negative top value of half of
that value then we hide the pseudo
elements with overflow:hidden put on the
table then we use negative that in next
we can actually copy paste the content
and we've got it and then we can of
course also use make also focus upon
focus that montage start maybe with a
bit of JavaScript right but when I saw
this for the first time in my life I
literally freaked out and even cried a
little bit just a little bit because you
can apply to the element
to the classes and can apply to the
classism to the elements can apply to
the elements and to the elements
probably and it can apply to the
classroom see the classes so at this
point what we're creating is we have
this table creating huge through the
element that covers the entire table
with a width of hundred percent because
this is the maximum width right and with
the height well we don't know what it's
going to be so we set it in ten thousand
pixels then we actually just move it all
up to minus five thousand pixels so it's
kind of centered and then we use you
know we put it to the left well just so
it's you know just to be sure and then
we use background color current color
just because we can and then we can use
that index minus one so we kind of push
the content to the top so above the
table so we can copy/paste it and we're
done right and we can also of course
apply to th as well if we want to it's
actually really simple now you don't
need to ask you for that right that's
pretty cool now this is not that bad
this is not too dirty
let's talk dirty so who has a pleasure
of eventually building email layouts
maybe responsive email layouts a few
people so these people who are building
responsive emails can you please come
after the talk in here so we can hug you
because this is really really bad I mean
this is really really difficult now
first of all it's not because you know
we don't have proper CSS support not
because we don't have proper job oh we
don't have JavaScript at all images are
not loaded usually what if alt and we
have to deal with things like Outlook
and other very similar creatures which
is no fun at all and you want to make it
responsive good luck because Google
Gmail does not support media queries
because of security reasons they say but
they will know if they are not intending
to support media queries so how would
you then build a responsive email that
works well in Gmail now especially if
you know if you're opening an email that
looks broken it's not like you're going
to go to desktop to seen in defense of
you you're just deleting it right so
well let's be fix it in fact when you're
talking about responsive email it feels
like we're really going back in time
when things used to be
you know mmm ie 6 & 7 & 8 things like
that because most of the time still
today although every second almost every
second email is opened on mobile
they still
most of the time so email designers and
developers to come up with very
interesting techniques including
background coloring for example because
images are not loaded by default except
if it's Gmail so they will be covering
kind of coloring the background cell
because of course you're using table
layouts at this point just in case table
layout so we can actually color every
cell now sometimes you can be really
creative with it I was working with a
guy who was in a project but it was
really important for them to actually
display an image even if image is not
displayed or cannot be displayed in
email client hmm so it was really really
important like it was a button it
couldn't be just a button obviously it
couldn't be just you know itself it
should had to be an image that had to be
displayed they came up with really
interesting idea again you will never
forget this but of course you can
transform or convert an image into an
HTML table by you know for every pixel
that you have in an image you can
convert it into 1 x 1 TD with that
background color it's going to be a big
huge HTML of course but if you set it if
you do it right and you put an anchor
around that table it will work in
Outlook right so this is what people
come up with now this is really bad I'm
not encouraging you to do it but just in
case you need to do it some people can
come up with really interesting ideas
right so this is like you know but we
can do some stuff because we have type
of properties that actually behave
properly so we can do you know if you
have let's say if you have let's say
like to here four columns
I think of six no no here four and here
- right if you want to move from four to
two columns you know with tables we can
do this we just have to display them as
block instead of table cell and set the
width properly right if we want to kind
of move the columns around we can also
do this by just using the table header
open table footer group properties there
are four of them there will footer group
table header group table caption and
table cell of course and something else
and the interesting part is if you look
into the spec and it's probably the best
thing you can do like spec is
best evening lecture you can have right
it's so fascinating sometimes because
you know with flexbox we can reorder
components or reorder kind of things in
the layout and Dom that's great but we
could do that with table properties as
well because if we have let's say free
problem three elements a b c and we want
to have we can't use media queries for
example for gmail but we want to
reshuffle them or reorder them to be a c
we just have to define B as stable
footer header group a as table cell and
C a stable food group and they're going
to reshuffle because the header always
lives above the table the food always
seems below the table and table cell in
between and table caption between the
table cell and table for the group right
so we can reshuffle up to four elements
in a very high can dirty way if we want
to make it work for you know all the
clients so that's great we're going to
use these kind of things everywhere and
sometimes you also need to use of course
this little thingy well just in case
you're wondering just for Yahoo because
they are otherwise doesn't understand
classes so we need to put it in the
attribute selector so that's kind of
nice in a way but this is what you will
end up with in the end right but this is
not quite what we want because we want
to make it work in Gmail so let's say we
have a four column layout and a large
screen we want to make it two columns in
a small screen on a small screen or
maybe even simpler we have two columns
from large screen and one column on the
small screen right we just want to stack
things in Gmail today we can make it
work or do you know how to make it work
now this is really really bad I mean
people who watch me at this point will
be totally devastated and go facepalm
all the time I think but we can make it
work with calc with with ant marks with
so can you tell me who is going to win
if we set this on our CSS box so we set
the width on 320 pixels we set the min
width on 480 pixels and marks with on
160 pixels
who is going who think that width is
going to win who thinks that men will
mean which is going to win good thing
that marks which is going to win who is
literally wondering what the hell I'm
doing here
so this is really interesting because
the answer is it depends so if we look
into the spec which is again and very
interesting lecture that they can
actually read at night you'll find read
a lot of interesting stuff for example
if the width value is greater than the
max with marks with winds now that we
understand that makes sense right
because marks which kind of restricts
the growth or restricts the width right
let's make sense however and that's the
interesting part if the mean weight
value is greater than the width or max
width then mean with winds okay let's
read it again if the min width value is
greater than the width or max width then
mean with winds we can abuse it in so
many different ways right so let's say
we want to make it work in Gmail without
media queue so how how can we do it like
this yes okay that's okay just bear with
me this is going to be fine now what the
hell are we going here we want to build
a two column layout that stacks and
grows below 480 pixels so below 480
pixels one column above 180 pixels two
columns we cannot use media queries for
this right so how do you make it work
well with this we set we set min with
some 50% max with 100% and we've as a
calque of 480 pixels minus 1% which is
our parent element x 480 why the hell
would you do that right so basically
this is like a two column desktop
version at this point and this is like a
one column mobile version 480 pixels is
our break point and obviously
hundred-percent refers to the parents to
the width of the parent so what are we
doing here our goal is to create a value
bigger than our max with all smaller
than our mean with so instead of with
mean with all max width is going to be
applied
right does it make sense so why does it
make sense so here we go let's say we
have again the breakpoint is 480 pixels
so with a parent of 500 pixels you know
it's more than 480 pixels right so what
do we have here mean width is going to
be 50% which is 250 pixels max width is
than 500 pixels and the width is - 9600
pixels right now at this point minutes
is going to win because if the minutes
value is greater than the width or
max-width min which is going to win okay
right so the code it is let me see
it's 150 pixels because it's loud it's
not larger than max width but it is
larger than width so it has to win all
right
on the other way around if we go below
480 pixels so we have let's say 400 here
we've got 200 pixels here we've got
former pixels and here we've got 38,400
X and fallen pixels and because max
width always restricts the width marks
which is going to win right and you're
done right and you could say well this
is not fancy enough maybe we could do
something else maybe we can use you know
JavaScript if javascript is not
supported and the answer is of course
you can right
how can you do this well what if you
wanted to build a real-time wall like
tweets to tweet a wall in an email when
you send it out can you make it work of
course you can now the question is how
external CSS now you can do better than
that
but that goes in the right direction you
can you deserve one I think anybody else
now obviously we can reference an image
which is going to live on the server
which is going to be updated every two
seconds and we then are going to crop it
and we're going to animate it a little
bit right so it appears as if it was
live and it's kind of life just maybe
with a five-second you know delay more
or less right and it kind of works right
that's pretty cool so that's you know
not a big deal in fact this is what what
they did for the email design conference
template and it's actually really
right that's pretty cool in fact if you
really indeed do have to deal with
responsive email there are two resources
I highly recommend one is their
responsive email patterns and the other
one responsive email resources and this
technique by the way is not for me but
from Remy Parmenter thanks Remy
so that's dirty but it's you know it
works alright here's the next one so you
want to add a background to inline text
for headings but the text should be
petted along both the left and right
edge of each line now the left and right
wedding will only apply to the very
first and very last line so if you apply
petting and you have you you know your
text surrounding it some here you've got
your padding right and here you've got
your padding but here you've got no
padding and here you've got no painting
either right so how would we fix it
sorry negative margin potentially yes
but then here you've got double padding
Oh box shadow okay
so what's that then why are you sitting
so far
okay I'll try again later all right in
fact we can do this just for you so I
hope it's okay yeah so we can do this by
just using the Bookshare method when we
just put the boxer on both sides and
we're done right so we're kind of
drinking a little bit but it's really
CSE just just adding a boxer on the both
sides and then you don't have really
petty but you kind of looks like you
have painting right well that's pretty
cool and it's really simple now let's go
something go a bit more interesting ways
maybe let's see okay I do want to not
this one but just a second sorry okay no
so here's the interesting one which is
just really useful in many scenarios so
what if you want to use a full with the
element in a fixed width container right
for example when you want some content
to extend beyond the boundaries of the
container this is what you want
sometimes you want to have like Elias
landing page and you have your container
where the text lives and of course you
want to restrict it because otherwise
the time the line length is going to be
too too big but that image could be kind
of breaking out of that layout right so
how do we do it we W all right well you
can have full screen that's not a
problem the problem is forward that you
actually do want to make sure this kind
of outside but you don't want to close
the first deep open like you know put
the image inside and then reopen the
other div again right so this is what
you of course could do well first of all
you want to restrict your container then
you have your diff and then you have
your piece over the images and so on and
what you will have to do then
potentially it's just close the div and
then reopen open the image and then
close open the deep again right but
that's not nice I mean in fact I mean an
areas that's not difficult right sorry
negative more that's good I like it
keep going okay all right that's okay
all right so in fact negative margins
work quite well here to release our
child element from its container I'm
very proud of the phrasing we need to
know how much
space series between the container and
the viewport edge right and we can
calculate it just by using calc again
right how again does it work well we can
just use negative V I don't mean here
I've got two margins right basically we
are pulling the content out but with
minus 50% with minus 50 VW first and
then we put it back with 50% on the
parent right of course in the width and
it just works again everywhere so just
we're just pulling it out and then we're
pulling it back with outside of the
scope of container and then kind of back
so it doesn't you know set a good price
full screen right and the problem
however is if we do this we end up with
this little bugger right
and so before because this happens we
actually need to also put all four
hidden on all four X hidden as well and
then we're really done right so in many
scenarios you would be using you know
really closing the diff and then
reopening it but you either you really
don't have to you can just pull it out
and it will work I think there was
something white wouldn't work but it's
my guy I would need to check it out but
it's a good one yeah all right okay
let's see what else let's go something
all right this is fun okay this is very
practical so you want to implement how
much time do I have actually oh no time
mm okay then I have to do just one okay
I mean but it's really not a big deal
seriously so just last one so happy hour
fun I'm sure you did I mean you'll get
all the slides anyway what is the best
way to encode and one times one pixel
would you use JPEG for that would you
use a gif for this we do use the PNG
what would you use why smaller give it
smaller
is it hmm let's see so that's
interesting some people have nothing to
do on the weekends welcome one times one
pixel give just in case you can't see it
here this kind of waving at you I don't
think that you realize and we could
think well this is not a big deal this
is not that difficult I mean this is not
really like you know it seemed kind of
simple
uncompressed pixel is just one bit right
oh four bytes depends again depends on
how we see it so if you look at the
black and white is going to be one bit
grayscale 1 byte grayscale and alpha
channel 2 bytes RGB 3 bytes RGB a 4
bytes right that's okay and you could
think well so that's it right this is it
well not quite if you want to encode it
using give or leaf or JPEG or whatever
and that case you will need to do a bit
more work because as it appears every
image format specifies not only you know
the actual image but also how to
interpret the data and also has some
metadata in it so for example the width
and the height and the number of bits
per bytes of ice per pixel and so on so
if you look specifically into what they
contain
you'll find that there is a magic number
which is like a user agent string in
browsers right it's kind of a fixed
identify which they kind of communicate
whether it's a gif or JPEG or PNG or
anything else it also has some decoding
details like all profiles orientation
gamma dose per pixel has some arbitrary
metadata potentially like things like
time stamps copyright notices or
coordinates and some overhead stuff like
markers and checksums or even pairings
for consistency just to make sure that
whenever the image is transmitted it's
always actually correct in the correct
shape and if you look inside you know
into the hex bond dump of it this is
what you will find right this is a PNG
this is a few markers even if it's just
you know one x one pixel and they differ
and the different size as well and some
people really spend time analyzing this
so this is a gif right and this is
Debbie P and it turns out if you look
into the table and compare what
different pixels have different values
right which is important to know but in
fact this most one is give for white and
everything else too
right and then you could say well this
is not interesting enough what about you
know a color it's like a real color so
if you actually put and go and explore
like there's not just one x one pixel
but let's say ten thousand pixels nine
ten thousand pixels what's going to be
the smallest and the answer is well it
depends of course but in that case the
smallest is going to be PNG which is
interesting by the way the reason why we
didn't include jpg and here is because
JP cannot be transparent and it was all
about transparent pixels right all right
well okay so no more time right are you
sure oh yes this is brilliant okay so
let's do this so that's what else oh my
god okay this is what this one is really
useful to so baseline ring or vertical
written right
every designer gets on somebody else's
nerves when it comes to basically like
the perfect vertical reading how do you
do it how do you make it right there are
so many great frameworks of course you
could use but do you have to use them
because you can actually make it really
simple now in the answer is one thing
you just have to keep in mind now if I
don't know if you can see oh wow they're
actually supposed to be like a little
grid behind so it depends really on how
you implement it now very often if you
think about the vertical reading you
think about the lines living between the
grid lines right so you have this lines
like the you have agreed and these lines
of text should be sitting right between
them right and they're kind of the same
distance between when they start in
between when the end or you could do it
slightly differently where you just put
the text on that line in the grid and
it's unlikely that you can see it's to
be honest but that's okay I will explain
it anyway so we tend to actually really
most of the time use just a multiple of
line height everywhere
use it for pairings and margins and
sometimes even border width right but we
can align to the by base line instead
right so for this to work we just need
to calculate the offset and then shave
the content by that offset so what does
it mean so let's say we have this lines
right imagine we have lines we have
lines everywhere right here right we
have lines in here everywhere and
here is a line and here is a line and
that line is right where the texts it's
all right right here not in here
just below it but actually right there
which I'm really bad at this right where
it's it's all right in that case this is
what we can do so by default how does it
work but default browser center the cap
height as they define it between the
grid lines so the height of the cap
height is the height of a capital letter
above the baseline again baseline is
where the text sits so we can shift it
by half the difference between line
height and cap height why well because
the tips text sits right between those
lines so if we just take half of that
line for example and we remove the top
of the line height then we actually have
the text sitting right on the base line
okay this didn't go as expected all
right we just need to determine the cap
height and then offset the entire thing
a little bit down and then we have to
pull it back with margin negative margin
at the bottom that's okay just a second
so this is how it's going to work so we
have our line height define power
formstack we could have different
typefaces for example right and we have
different font sizes in the end we're
doing pixels here we're using pixels
here but you can of course transform
them into e/m units later so it's more
flexible it just for us to be easier it
kind of to follow easier simpler so we
have the font sizes and then we just
have to kind of refine it with cap
heights a little bit with the formula
you will see in a second so once we
define them we just plugged in a formula
and it works right so how exactly does
it work in the end we have this little
sauce mix in where we define the font
size and cap height an offset and
returns that actual offset by again
using that formula which I said before
where we're kind of using the half of
the line height minus cap height times
font size right it will make sense just
don't have time to explain everything
right and the only thing we have to do
is kind of put that off so once we
define the offset calculated the offset
we just need to push it a little bit
down so it sits right on the baseline in
order to do this
we use we can use this and this is
really like a magic trick
most front-end developers will will
freak out at this point because you can
use margin top and margin bottom and it
could you know weed here you have you
have offset so you're pushing all the
text a little bit down to see it on the
baseline and design it out of you know
not to screw up everything you have to
pull it back with margin bottom for the
for the when the paragraph ends right
for example if you have a set the
paragraphs you want them all to be
sitting right right so what you have to
split back so you still have this
consistence in terms of how the lines
and how they go so once you have this
you might be wondering what the hell is
going on here and you are free to leave
at this point it's like two minutes left
so how does it why does it work because
we have collapsing margins in CSS if you
look into this back in the evening at
night you'll be able to find some really
interesting facts about how it works as
it turns out collapsing margins are not
always collapsing margins so they work
differently with positive and negative
margins you have two positive margins
the bigger one will win and like imagine
you have a margin bottom and you have a
margin top right I mean if you're doing
CSS you will know this stuff if you have
two positive values on two consequence
paragraphs the one with the bigger value
will win if you have two negative
margins the lower well I'm the one that
is more negative is going to win if you
have one positive and one negative
they're going to add so the Marches will
sum up we can abuse it in so many
different ways right because this is
exactly what we can do and what we are
doing here anyway right we have always
positive one and another one is negative
and this is exactly what we can use so
they will be added up and they will
maintain this vertical written that we
want so what do we have in the end only
one problem we have only one problem if
an element doesn't have a border no
padding and this first child has a
margin that margin will flow out of the
parent right because we define the
negative margin but the actual parent
has no you know has no padding so it's
going to flow out so we need to put all
four hidden on it
that's okay if you could see the lines
you will see that all of this text is
sitting on right on this on the grid
line without us having to do anything
without any media queries without
anything just works using a little bit
of you know cook calc is like magic it's
like you know flexbox
calc and you don't that's all you need
to know what CSS person seriously if you
want to learn more about this and just
use the mixin here we go right
implementing baseline reading in CSS
doesn't take much time at all so this in
mind I'm very sorry I have to give away
some chocolates just just because you
okay who is really desperate in
desperately needs chocolate now oh these
people all right these people they want
chocolate all right okay sorry
so I'm taking up the time that was
really bad I'm sorry
all right so you can just pick it up
later that's easy all right so I've got
like the the slide deck is public
it's already on slide deck so you can
download it and with that in mind thank
you and if you want to talk more about
dirty stuff and CSS and not necessarily
say such a dirty just come to me and
we'll talk all right thank you